so if you get a win tonight that would
be confidence going into those next four
games against teams in the similar spots
beside you in the table
where you from Jim Ireland
I like your accent it's tough I want to
learn how to talk like that
but
extra question again I was too much
listening to your action yeah no problem
and
you have Popeyes there
yeah man I had to Popeyes after the game
thanks man appreciate your time
appreciate it
what's up nephews
how long y'all don't ask no questions
yeah I'm trying to put an order in
McDonald's
yeah
Chris he said no questions
yeah right right tell them to lock in
man
wait
customize no ice
I like Minnesota y'all I love Minnesota
man
hope you all love me back do that great
yeah I just got it hold on let me pay
for it
alone two seconds
like these lights but
look is there anybody that you would
ever back down against when you see who
was in front of you there
you're you're not too far removed from
Summer League what's the best memory you
take from your side of Lucas uh you know
I didn't play uh we had covet my year
was covered yeah so we didn't play yeah
that's right that's right well look so
when you see this out here like man they
lucky I I wasn't I was they lucky I
wasn't able to play because I would have
killed these boys
I I used to play baseball when I was
young yeah it'd be hot really how good a
baseball player were you I could have
went to the MLB
MLB yeah I am not surprised I'm serious
though you think I'm joking I'm serious
no I just I love your confidence what
positions did you play I played pitcher
shortstop third base and center field
those are the prime positions that what
I'm trying to tell you yeah you were the
best player on your team is that now we
talking you could hit the ball but I was
fourth fifth hitter you know what I mean
clean up yeah straight clean up on aisle
three come come get it sounds like
you're just an athlete yeah
any okay ping pong baseball football
basketball tennis swimming lacrosse
whatever you need me to play I'm gonna
go do it if it's some money online I'm
gonna go do it can you golf whatever you
need me to do okay
hockey whatever owners on a ring
whatever you need me to do it don't
matter got it trash can ball we can
whatever you want trash can cook food
cook food that's something I bet I'll be
A1 from day one
two minutes ago in the third quarter
this might recognize this guy Anthony
Edwards all right before we get to the
questions put Timberwolves fans at ease
you are healthy you're just not
participating yes yes yes Timberwolves
fan I'm back 100 my ankle is good I'm
just chilling right now all right so
it's summertime you know we're out in
Vegas what have you been up to this
summer anything fun and unusual because
I know you've been working on your game
uh I learned a new
um I got a new hobby bowling I'm really
good at bowling now oh yeah like strikes
yeah bumpers or no two man come on man
like 200 I'm going to 200 for sure okay
that's not what we talked about
pre-interview tell me about Lake
Minnetonka oh yeah man you know I um I
got baptized in uh Lake Minnetonka uh I
hit a couple backflips you know uh
swimming I'm going back out there real
soon meet me at Lake Minnetonka all
Minnesota fans I'm going back out there
uh jet skis everything we're gonna have
fun can you swim yeah like Michael
Phelps like Michael Phelps yeah okay
yeah all right guys before this gets out
of hand enough in case you didn't
talented baby
I play pretty good defense then I'm
gonna be good on offense see my earring
dance
I see that yeah do you have any thoughts
about him are you an A-Rod fan at all
growing up or anything like that what do
you think about what he might bring to
the team
oh man
the baseball player Alex Rodriguez
yeah
okay I know he's gonna be the owner but
I don't I don't I don't know about
baseball okay
um
[Music]
hey yo
this is
my boy